hey everyone this is Rachel Buchholz
with National Geographic Kids magazine
I'm here at the academy of awesomeness
where I got to sit down with Jack Black
star of the new movie Kung Fu Panda he
also happens to be the guest editor of
this month's National Geographic Kids
magazine why did you decide to become a
guest editor for National Geographic
Kids magazine when I heard that that I
had have an opportunity to guest edit I
thought I wonder if I can edit I hope
I'm a good editor and you guys said oh
I'll be easy don't worry we're not gonna
let it be bad cuz we're gonna say that
you're gonna edit but really we're gonna
edit and you'll just say that you're the
editor that's all right so the first
thing I wanted to do is show you the
spread that you participated in as our
guest editor first spread is all about
you yeah with your favorite animal the
cheetah because it likes to run really
fast yeah that's true and good nice so
you like this I do yeah yeah what's this
guy doing there
that's a BMX yeah did you told us that
you uh that was one of your favorite
sports that's true this it really is
about me all about you I love it why do
you think it's important for kids to
learn about the world around them like
they do in National Geographic Kids
magazine
it's the best education you can get is
to learn about the the rest of the world
and the different perspectives oh the
Furious Five you're so much bigger than
your action figures except for you
mantis you're about the same what
message do you hope that kids get out of
the movie Kung Fu Panda well one of the
messages in the movie is to be your own
hero and that the secret to becoming a
master of any of the arts is to learn
about yourself and know yourself and be
yourself
why don't you try again a little harder
how's that a lot of the animals in the
movie Kung Fu Panda are endangered in
real life why do you think it's
important for kids to care about
endangered animals in the world that
they live in well because we're all
living creatures and we share this earth
and this planet and it's all part of a
delicate ecosystem and want to make sure
that that we take care of all the little
creatures and and and big creatures too
can you give our reader some green tips
so that they can help protect the
environment well it's all about energy
and cleanliness you don't want to stink
if you ever feel like you're stinking
something up stop doing that and um and
you don't want to be wasteful you know
if you if you can find a way to just
save energy and you know not use
electricity that you don't absolutely
have to doing a good thing for the world
thank you so much for being our guest
editor this month we really appreciate
it
my pleasure thank you for having me as
the guest editor we have a little gift
for you from National Geographic hat and
our really wild animals DVD for your not
a very good hat person I see if it fits
my head right you can read more about
Jack Black and Kung Fu Panda in this
month's issue of National Geographic
Kids magazine until next time I'm Rachel
Buchholz reminding you to keep on
exploring your world
no Leopard fun fact